sono nata ribelle
e fin da piccola ho sempre seguito alle
mie passioni
quindi sono una diversa difficilmente
etichettabile e mi sono spesso chiesta
perché
Sono figlia di una donna nata nella
Spagna di Franco da una famiglia di
Agricoltori benestanti che però dopo la
guerra non aveva abbastanza soldi per
mandare a scuola tutti quindi mia mamma
femmina assetata di informazioni
è stata costretta a lasciare gli studi i
suoi fratelli che invece non avevano
nessuna voglia di studiare sono stati
obbligati ad andare a scuola
lei spolverava la libreria e ogni tanto
si soffermava prima un libro per
leggerlo e le veniva detto non devi
spolverare
non devi leggere Scusate devi spolverare
poi lei un giorno si è ribellata e ha
girato mezza Europa facendo la
centrifuga per negli anni 50
poi ho conosciuto mio padre un italiano
si è sposata e ha fatto quello che tutti
si aspettavano che lei facesse
ha guidato fino a Quasi 90 anni
Però non si può certo dire che abbia
avuto una vita felice
fra un mese ne compie 94 e parla con
nostalgia dei tempi in cui era
indipendente
io ho osservato per anni la vita di mia
mamma è quella di mio padre lo scontro
di due culture mentalità diverse
posizioni rigide nessuna capacità di
dialogo
osservavo il dolore di una famiglia
apparentemente felice
e sono fuggita
sono fuggita perché io ero identica mia
mamma e non volevo finire come lei
io volevo
poter essere me stessa e non
necessariamente quello che gli altri mi
dicevano che dovevo essere
facile a fuggire
molto difficile
13 anni fa ha fondato un'azienda che si
occupa di sessualità e lavora
principalmente con le donne
la sessualità è una dimensione molto
ampia che ci accompagna per tutto il
percorso della nostra vita da quando
nasciamo quando moriamo ed è
condizionata da tantissimi fattori
culturali sociali economici politici
religiosi fisici e condizionata anche
dall'educazione che ci hanno dato dal
nostro sviluppo
psicologico e mentale
dal nostro vissuto personale
e dall'autostima da quella
dall'autostima che noi abbiamo di noi
stessi e del soprattutto su questo punto
che noi lavoriamo
e nonostante la sessualità sia ancora un
tabù
per la maggior parte delle persone in
tutte le parti del mondo
condiziona inevitabilmente il nostro
benessere fisico e psicologico per
definizione della oms è innegabile
Quindi se non abbattiamo il tabù non
possono esserci benessere fisico e
psicologico e senza questi
l'autostima diminuisce non c'è
empowerment
Noi lavoriamo principalmente con le
donne perché questo è un tabù questo
tabù è una discriminazione che si
declina soprattutto al femminile
attenzione ho detto soprattutto
non esclusivamente
noi lottiamo ogni giorno perché la
sessualità il piacere siano possano
essere vissuti come un diritto e non
consensi di colpa ogni giorno
Oggi siamo un'azienda la cui
professionalità e le cui capacità sono
riconosciute e apprezzate anche a
livello europeo ma non è sempre stato
così non è sempre stato così quando io
ho cominciato a parlare di sessualità 13
anni fa
ed è uscito il primo trafiletto sul
giornale locale
gli amici mi hanno tolto il saluto per
strada
semplicemente andavo in via Roma e si
giravano dall'altra parte da qui in poi
è stato un crescendo di
opposizioni a tutti i livelli di tutti i
tipi dal prete che non accettava i figli
delle nostre consulenti ai centri estivi
a grandi multinazionali e gruppi bancari
che facevano e fanno tutt'oggi mobbing
oppure dicono Molto esplicitamente O lei
o loro o noi gli stessi gruppi bancari
che ancora oggi non ci vogliono aprire
il conto corrente per l'argomento che
trattiamo
e che convocano un comitato regionale
per giudicare la nostra pagina web che
invece viene presa ad esempio sia come
immagine che come concetti trasmessi da
tutta l'Europa Come si permettono i
gruppi bancari di giudicare quello che
facciamo
chi gli ha dato questo diritto
abbiamo perso almeno 10 valide
collaboratrici per questo motivo però ce
n'è una che ha lasciato la grande
multinazionale ed è rimasta con noi
nel 2019 la società per la quale con la
quale lavoriamo per con i post Noi
abbiamo più di 60 post e che ci fa anche
i pagamenti online
senza
preavviso improvvisamente ci ha bloccato
tutti gli incassi non abbiamo incassato
una lira per 10 giorni
oggi Anzi due mesi fa con la stessa
società però ha cambiato la sua Policy
interna a livello europeo
e tutte le aziende qualsiasi azienda di
qualsiasi settore può usufruire di
questi servizi avere il pagamento
tramite posta a distanza e vendere
online Grazie solo alla nostra
caparbietà
un piccolo una piccola grande vittoria
per noi un atto politico
lascito Per i posteri
siamo presuntuose
siamo brave
quindi
perché le grandi battaglie non si fanno
con grandi azioni si fanno con piccole
azioni tutti i giorni della nostra
quotidianità e questo lo dico
soprattutto a tutte le persone che
pensano che i femminismi si portino
avanti solo partecipando alle grandi
manifestazioni e facendo grandi denunce
non è così e nella nostra quotidianità
che dobbiamo prendere piccole decisioni
portarle avanti e imporle nel nostro
habitat di tutti i giorni Se vogliamo
che i nostri figli vivevano in una
società diversa
noi per fortuna
[Applauso]
tante opposizioni Ma ci sono anche tante
conferme arrivate da tante parti se no
non saremo qua anche il mondo
scientifico che all'inizio ci guardava
con terrore
adesso ci accompagna ci supporta Ognuno
sta al suo posto Noi siamo il nostro
loro stanno a loro ma per me la più
grande conferma e qui mi riallaccio un
po' al racconto iniziale quella avuta da
mia mamma che come si può comprendere
quando abbiamo Quando ho iniziato questa
avventura era sotto shock
Ma poi ogni tanto veniva da me mi
sentiva fare questi colloqui con gli
aspiranti consulenti che continua a fare
tuttora mi piacciono tantissimo
finché un giorno mi dice ma mi domanda
alla fine quello che fai è educazione
sessuale per adulti
Sì mami e allora ci pensa un attimo mi
guarda e dice
sono nata troppo presto
Prendiamo esempio perché Quasi 90 anni
un'apertura di mentalità così da una
donna nata nel 1930 e cresciuta in un
collegio di suore è un esempio credo da
seguire quindi
mi sento arrivata no
mai
non esiste vita se non c'è anche solo
una piccola progettualità che Ci obbliga
che ci Motiva ad andare avanti ci sono
momenti nella mia vita in cui mi sento
intrappolata assolutamente
intrappolata in situazioni nelle quali
non vedo possibilità di evoluzioni
Allora faccio cambiamenti radicali
a costo di ricominciare da capo un nuovo
progetto magari all'interno dello stesso
progetto una strada diversa che liberi
me e che metta le ali al progetto
l'ultimo grande cambiamento è stato
quello di andare in Spagna nell'aranceto
di famiglia e farmene anche carico il
sogno di una vita Certo ma anche un
liberare chi verrà dopo di me dalla mia
presenza Un dare la possibilità di
creare
un'equipe con una personalità propria e
avere accanto la mia guida Non imporre
la mia guida sto fuggendo di nuovo
non sto facendo amo talmente tanto il
progetto e credo talmente tanto in
quello che faccio che non voglio che
muoia con me Non voglio che muoia con me
quindi non sto buttando via quello che
ho costruito
la lancetta è solo l'ennesima porticina
che apro con curiosità infantile e mi
permette di scoprire un nuovo mondo
naturalmente quei lati positivi e i lati
negativi e fra i lati positivi ho
scoperto un signore oltre ottantenne che
sta trasformando il suo Aranceto in un
campo di avvocato quindi mi innestic
attecchiscono che non attecchiscono modo
di potere diverso irrigazione diversa e
sua moglie gli dice Ma smettila e lui mi
ha detto Se smetto muoio
lui
insegue il suo sogno per mantenersi vivo
e l'ha capito
Ma quando li vedrai i suoi avocado
Eppure insegue il suo sogno
se lo fa lui Io ho ancora tempo per
trovare quelle equilibrio che mi
permetterà di essere coerente con me
stessa e anche questa è passione
prendere coscienza
dei miei desideri di ciò che conta e di
ciò che non conta per me perché nessuno
ha il diritto di fare questa scelta al
posto mio ma io ho il dovere di farla
nei miei confronti e le passioni possono
cambiare non sono le stesse le passioni
di oggi e di quelli di quando ero
ragazzina o di quelle di 10 anni fa e
non saranno le stesse fra 10 anni un
cammino che costruiamo da soli ed è per
questo che è un cammino coraggioso
una scelta difficile quella di vivere
con passione che ha valore solo se è una
scelta
consapevole siamo Siamo disposti a
prenderci il buono il cattivo Siamo
disposti a prenderci il bello e il
brutto se noi pensiamo che vivere con
passione abbia solo dei risvolti
positivi Siamo degli incoscienti
se vediamo solo le parti negative Beh
allora rimaniamo pure nella nostra zona
nella nostra comfort zone Ma se la
risposta è sì
Io sono cosciente e voglio vivere la mia
vita allora diventa una decisione
coraggiosa e non c'è coraggio senza
paura La paura non deve essere vergogna
bisogna vergognarsi di avere paura la
paura e ciò che ci impedisce di prendere
decisioni
avventate inconsapevoli e quella che ci
Protegge dai rischi
mi domando Certo sarebbe stato più
comodo se io
mi fossi adattata non avessi deciso di
seguire tutte queste passioni avrei
avuto una vita più facile ma come
sarebbe stata questa mia vita
sicuramente
non sarei fuggita a 16 anni e mi sarei
adattata agli studi che non mi piacevano
alla vita questa difficile vita in
famiglia probabilmente sarei diventata
molto più pragmatica e rassegnata
probabilmente avrei accettato il lavoro
in banca che mi proponeva mio padre
avrei meno preoccupazioni sicuramente
trascorrere pomeriggi in spiaggia perché
abitavo Imperia non avrei vissuto né a
Lucca né a Parigi però non sentirei i
fiori d'arancio il profumo dei Fiori
d'arancio tutte le mattine quando apro
la finestra non mi sveglierei col
cinguettio degli uccellini che confondo
con la sveglia dell'iPhone non avrei 100
donne appassionate che si aspettano che
tiri fuori una bacchetta magica che non
ho non starei 10 o 12 ore davanti al
computer forse sarei ancora sposata
non dovrei difendermi in continuazione
dalle opposizioni che ho sempre generato
che continua a generare
e che genererà sempre
però
ho una sola vita e non posso sprecarla
Non sprecate le vostre vite Non sprecate
le vostre vite
spesso mi prende la voglia di fuggire e
sono fuggita tutte le volte che ho
voluto farlo finché un giorno un amico
mi ha detto
trasformi dalle banalità in cose
meravigliose dai il significato cose che
non hanno significato e poi quando è il
momento di tenere duro e di portarti a
casa il risultato del lavoro che hai
fatto mogli e lasci tutto ad altri
rimboccati le maniche e portati a casa
ciò che è tuo
bella sberla
Ma le sberle fanno bene
e quindi adesso tutte le volte che mi
viene voglia di fuggire Io penso a
quella Perla e rimango al mio posto
contro tutto e tutti e anche contro me
stessa
contro la paura di affrontare durante
giorni
determinate situazioni per paura della
decisione che so che dovrò prendere che
poi dovrò portare avanti Ma li rimango
perché lo devo a me stessa e non lo devo
più solo a me stessa ma lo devo tutte le
persone che credono in me hanno creduto
in me continuano a credere in me E lo
devo anche a mio figlio che ha cambiato
la sua vita in parte anche per seguire i
miei passi
sfidando se stesso nella gestione di
un'azienda di tutte donne che si rivolge
prettamente a un pubblico femminile
tendiamo a vivere l'ho già detto come
gli altri si aspettano che noi viviamo
le persone intorno a noi
confondendo lo spesso con ciò che noi
vogliamo ma semplicemente perché non ci
fermiamo a riflettere fermiamoci a
riflettere se noi lo facessimo
spesso e lo decidessimo delle risposte
sincere nella maggior parte dei casi ci
risponderemmo quando ci domandiamo Ma
perché mi comporto così ma perché sto
agendo in questo modo se fossimo sinceri
la maggior parte delle volte ci
risponderemmo non lo so
oppure perché si fa così
io
ho sempre detto Ma chi lo ha detto che
si fa così e perché si fa così
non ho mai accettato Quando portavo
l'esasperazione i miei genitori e mi
dicevano perché si e basta sono le
domande che mi sono sempre fatta da
bambina che continua a farmi da grande
e alle quali ho sempre cercato di darmi
delle risposte sincere e ho sempre agito
in conseguenza
facendomi carico e rendendomi
responsabile dei risvolti sia positivi
che negativi
Ho lottato per ottenere e Lotto tutti i
giorni per mantenere i diritti che
considero miei l'unico diritto che non
ho E che soprattutto non voglio avere è
quello di dare la colpa a qualcun altro
di ciò che succede a me
e di questo sono orgogliosa